AI is disrupting jobs we didn't quite
imagine be disrupted first we we thought
it'd be accountants or whatever and what
it ends up being is artists creators I
mean I just saw a website today for
model agency you can get an AI model yep
and you can't tell and so you can Define
exactly what race color age any
requisite you want and it makes it
perfectly it's going to change a lot of
jobs it's also going to offer a lot of
opportunity so all of us will be
thinking about AI strategy like in the
late 90s we all think about internet
strategy when we're building businesses
we're lucky because the human population
of most of the western developed world
is diminishing over time I it's aging
and we're not replacing ourselves so we
replace ourselves with AI and machines
so we're seeing Amazon warehouses a
third of the Amazon Workforce is robots
but they're three or four times more
productive than humans so therefore we
will see endless build-outs of robots
instead of humans it is augmentation of
humans
and it's amazing
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe Nation hey seven Carmichael and
I make these videos because in my first
business I struggle to stay afloat I
quit I'm a business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the thinking that maybe I
can do it too that actually a bit of
belief and I still need their stories
today and I'm honored to share them with
you here as well so taylorson from one
of the best railroad Paul and my take on
his top 10 rules of success
enjoy
we're lucky because the human population
of most of the western developed world
is diminishing over time I it's aging
and we're not replacing ourselves so we
replace ourselves with AI and machines
so we're seeing at Amazon warehouses
um a third of the Amazon Workforce is
robots but they're three or four times
more productive than humans so therefore
we will see endless build-outs of robots
instead of humans
an AI is disrupting jobs we didn't quite
imagine be disrupted first we we thought
it would be
accountants or whatever and what it ends
up being is artists creators I mean I
just saw a website today uh for model
agency
where you can get an AI model yep and
you can't tell
and so you can Define exactly what race
color age any requisite you want and it
makes it perfectly
so I'm like okay I didn't expect the
modeling industry to get disrupted
because how many people actually go to
catwalks it's not it's for video or
photography
so it's going to change a lot of jobs
it's also going to offer a lot of
opportunities all of us will be thinking
about AI strategy like in the late 90s
we all think about internet strategy
when we're building businesses fine okay
we can deal with that
the issue is
Moore's Law
and the exponentiality of all of this
so these language models these large
language models llms which GPT came out
with
are increasing exponentially in their
power
of an order of magnitude that we can't
get our heads around because we think in
linear terms because we're dumb humans
so these things are doubling tripling
every year or less
and this was the fastest you've heard me
use this phrase before the fastest
adoption of technology in all history
was crypto blockchain technology
chat GPT went from zero to a hundred
million users in a month
Okay so
so now we've got AI that is like a virus
it is so Unstoppable
and we've got two or three different
people building it
at scale Google
Amazon Microsoft with openai and then
stability AI is an open source Network
AI which is almost Unstoppable because
it's doubly viral
because you've got so this is going on
the computational power is exploding the
cost of computers going down
and what it means is that AI becomes
more and more powerful so if you listen
to Mo gordat and he knows because he ran
Google X
where a lot of this has been incubated
they discovered deep mind they were the
people really to build out the the large
language models
um
he says well right now
specific AI is better at humans in
almost everything it does
so specific AI has a better result set
than any radiologist on Earth
and just for people that don't know
specific AI or narrow AI is it's one
task go get good at reading an x-ray go
get go to playing chess playing go
whatever
so okay fine
they think that Mo God thinks that by
the end of this decade
AGI
so that's a generalist AI so like humans
or chat GPT is a general as a general
you can navigate a grocery store you can
play chess you can play in the markets
uh guess what the weather's going to be
like anything anything you know like
like I could ask you a question you can
ask me a question
so
he thinks that with the computational
power and the progression of where this
is going that it's almost
certain that by the end of this decade
we get to the point where AI is smarter
than humans
now we don't really worry about that
because we already think it's smarter
than us are doing certain things and
soon it'll be smarter driving cars and
it'll really smile for us flying planes
we just kind of take it for granted we
don't see it
but then if you get to the Ray Kurzweil
Singularity point
so and mo gordat says okay here's the
really big problem and this is exactly
what Noah Harari says as well is when
you take it extrapolated a little bit
further out into the future so Ray
kurzweil's Singularity moment is 20 49.
but even before then
it becomes a thousand times smarter
than the smartest person who ever lived
rule number two is buy Bitcoin now if
I'm an investor who wants to I feel like
I don't have a big enough spot position
in either Bitcoin ethereum cardano L
Grand whatever you know I'm looking to
take out our position in would you say
you know in the next either now or the
next three months or six months is the
time I should be looking to buy
so you kind of either by now
and this is where the market is
struggling with this because few people
have flipped out because they made some
money got called the low yeah the people
with short-term time Horizons
um others like it's overbought but
usually these kind of conditions are
where you tend to get these crazy legs
to the upside because everybody's
underweight because everyone's got the
same thing as you as I don't have enough
spot what do I do then you have to fomo
in and you'll end up fomo in too high so
this is how it is written it is always
this way
um and so
I my my best guess and I don't know I
don't have a crystal ball but usually
because it's set up like this the pain
of the path of most pain is higher
and then once everybody goes right it's
going it's running it's running it's
usually when this correction happens so
do you get another chance to buy it
again at these levels if you miss it now
maybe we don't know if it has that
downward correction or the sideways
correction
you will get up time to buy after a
consolidation later but really I would
be and this is what I've been doing is
buying you know I was buying from June
onwards as much as I could with any cash
flow I got because I'm still fully
invested in crypto I never sold anything
but I've been any cash flow I can just
putting it in is okay even now I've just
you know just put money in recently
expecting a higher move and then if that
consolidation comes that's when I would
add some more again
so
if you're a longer term time Horizon
player I'm not talking about the short
term I don't know maybe I'm wrongly or
right but I don't find this a bad level
to to dollar cost average or just put a
chunk in and realize that there is going
to be times when it's going to correct
again
but the lowest in rule number three is
think about the future how are you
deploying AI in real Vision so the game
is going to be about this is like the
internet
because of what you said everybody's
building AI
and it's going to be how you utilize it
and your data set
you know you can say well everyone had
the the internet yeah but Amazon Google
and a few others won
at this phase of the internet so we've
been given something else like this and
it comes ready trained with some stuff
and then we can build on top so you're
putting your own data in it's the impact
Theory it'll be the tombow so we're
thinking okay what can we do with AI
within real vision
by having proprietary stuff we've you
know for example I've written eight 19
years of research part of global macro
investor okay so that's that's an
interesting data set
there's also every transcript of every
interview we've ever done every action
taken by everyone the website and then
so on and so forth so it's going to be
about
who gets the best data sets
and how do you use them
um my view is the best use case for all
of this is to create network Effects by
giving the value of what we call the
hive mind
so if all of the people not just me and
experts but everybody because they're
all learning from being on real Vision
much as they are with impact Theory so
they become smarter because of it so get
all their interactions and give it back
to them
and then eventually allow people to
build on top of it how are you giving it
back to them well because it it's it's
you you you're basically surveying all
the information held within the hive
mind
distilling it down and giving it back to
them as opposed to the old model which
would be monetizer eyeballs in a
different way
here is the
Consolidated wisdom of the crowd go
forth and use this as you will yes and
if you want to build on top of it add
more crowd information into it but it's
going to be the quality of the data set
that matters and how people use it and
people try all sorts of different things
we're not going to use it for oh should
I buy the s p today
because a it's a legal nightmare to do
it
and B we actually believe in giving
people the knowledge rule number four is
learn how that works so the big issue
for me is how do you make GDP
GDP is a magic formula
it's basically population growth
plus productivity
plus debt growth
those three things make GDP growth
that's how economies grow
population growth
well I think you know by now that almost
every single population in the western
world including Japan and China is now
shrinking
so that is an unprecedented thing for us
to have to deal with
now normally you would have had
immigration but because we had so much
immigration and wages haven't gone up
people said okay we can't really take
immigration at that scale to drive GDP
growth
okay so that was the decision people
made and I understand why
um and it's very difficult to import a
large population of people when the
wages of the existing population are too
low
so we can't solve population growth
it is a fixed we know what it is
and immigration is not going to solve it
so therefore we've got debt growth well
debt growth has been the engine of which
we've driven everything
and we got to a point where debt
is around in the US about 220 percent of
GDP that's private sector debts and
government debts
so we've got to a very indebted world
now you can get more indebted but I'll
come into the debt side later and it's
something I've written up in great
detail in macro insiders and Global
macro investor
but also let's look at the productivity
side this is the only dial that I think
we could actually move now if we can't
really move debt growth in any
meaningful way and we can't move
population growth then productivity has
to be the answer and that is the focus I
think of where this is all going
solving productivity so what is my
thesis here
my thesis is
that the debt service costs
must be less than GDP growth
if not it needs to be monetized I don't
think anybody else has really talked
about this
but I went back and I wrote about it a
lot in in macro insiders Pro macro and
also Global macro investor in great
detail but basically
if the government is a hundred percent
of GDP in debt in the private sector is
100 let's make the maths easy
okay if
GDP growth long-term trend is call it
1.75 percent maybe lower maybe a bit
higher but it's around that
so if interest rates on the debt burn
which is 100 of GDP just for the
government
is more than 1.75 percent
then GDP which is all of the earnings of
the economy
don't service the debt so it has to come
out of GDP itself which means GDP
shrinks
or the rate of growth slows now we've
got an issue where we've got two sectors
that are both 100 of GDP this all broke
when this started happening so we've got
two sectors now competing for GDP to pay
interest
okay that would be a problem we'd have a
continually shrinking economy
but the Japanese figured this out a long
time ago
the answer was to monetize the
government side of the balance sheet
and what they're actually doing
and I think I've proven it in Pro macro
and Global macro investor that all of
the QE
is essentially
monetizing the interest payments every
three and a half years based on a cycle
from the debt refunding cycle that
starts when rates hit zero in 2009 and
that has led these three to five year
debts keep getting rolled the economy
rolls over because rates get higher at
the top rates go up at the top of the
cycle the whole economy slows down
and eventually you try and refund at the
bottom of the cycle and that goes on to
the balance sheet and the difference
between
the GDP growth and the um
the size of the debt is actually what
goes on to the balance sheet itself and
that seems to equate to the interest
payments so basically government debt
growth as a percent of GDP is actually
or in total is actually just to monetize
the debt itself to pay the interest I.E
you're borrowing more to pay the
interest and then that goes on to the
balance sheet
that's pure
monetization that is pure
devaluation of a currency
without anybody really understanding it
and obviously asset prices go up also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free work
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is step out of
your comfort zone do you think your best
trade is still ahead of you
my best trade
is always the same
it's in quality of life
and that quality of life is everything
from friends family
how you live not where you live not in
your material possessions
it's how you live your life
having a Lust For Life
a cure curiosity
enjoying being outside of your comfort
zone I've talked about this before
there's your comfort zone and there's
where the magic happens and they don't
overlap
it's it's that experience of life itself
is the best trait
and the game is to accumulate
as much
quality of life and that can be a walk
in nature
or it could be it doesn't have to be
anything it's not Material it's a
quality of life and if you've got that
and your bank is full your bank your
account is full of quality of life and
quality of life experiences that's the
greatest trait on Earth and I'll
continue to do that trade until the day
I die well number six is study crypto
the most important thing about
understanding crypto is understanding
how to price it
and how I price crypto is essentially
two major factors one is global
liquidity and I use Global M2 as the
main understanding of that and then
there's the long and that's the cyclical
element and then there's the
technological adoption which is the
long-term logarithmic trend
so let's deal with the cycle first the
cycle is what causes all of the pain
and I've been in this space since 2013
and trust me I know pain the first time
I bought Bitcoin was at 200 it went up
to
um I think it was
a thousand then back down 85 languish
for a year or two and then went up 10x
from my entry price where I sold out
and then it came back down again after
getting up another 10x then it came back
down again
um and I've seen these cycles and at
first a lot of people correlated them to
the Bitcoin halving cycle and I think
that's probably coincidental and it's
the fact that the economic Cycle Works
in about the same time Horizon this four
year period after 2008 that the Bitcoin
halving cycle does because it was born
out of the crisis
and really what I think is going on is
it's the debt refi cycle because there's
so much debt in the global economy and
what happens is they try and tighten
rates and then you've got to refile of
this debt and rates come all the way
back down again liquidity comes back and
I think the stasis the natural tendency
is for there to be ongoing stimulus
because a overly indebted economy and if
you think of GDP growth being
population growth plus productivity
growth well with aging populations
that's out of the equation and it seems
that immigration is a political no-go
particularly with uh real wages so
stagnant
it's only got productivity growth now
that's not been growing either so the
only way of funding GDP has been debt
but now it takes
three dollars of debt to drive one
dollar of GDP we kind of get to the end
game and there's just so much debt out
there it never gets paid back so the
only way of running an economy now is
allowing for the increase in debt but
what services the debt is the cash flows
so therefore GDP growth must be higher
than debt growth if not you need to run
negative real rates GDP growth because
of Aging populations low productivity
has come down too low to service debt
growth and therefore you run negative
real rates quantitative easing and other
such stimulus that is the way the world
Works rule number seven is focus on
digital assets it's really hard to argue
that when you've just seen what we've
seen in AI and so I just want people to
focus on that drop all their
preconceptions aside all the bare Fest
that's going on right now and say I need
to un my future 10 years out
what am I going to do Rel this is what
I'm telling you the best thing I can do
the other one
is digital assets I've made this super
clear I think it's the best bet in the
world I think it's much better than the
exponential age bet because it's
exponential in its own right and again
cyclical Turning Point on a secular
Trend so very quickly there's the child
Bitcoin there's the logarithmic uptrend
two standard deviations oversold this is
where you want to be buying it so that
kind of makes total sense to me and
guess what it's cyclical because it's
cyclical based on global money supply
within a secular Trend so the ups and
downs in that secular Trend are actually
driven by money supply makes total sense
all assets are the same so there we go
Bitcoin Global money supply Global money
supply is turned up
where is global money supply going to be
in six months time tighter or looser
0.0 chances tighter
because inflation is going to fall just
mathematically
so it either stays the same or it goes
looser so what it's saying is this is
the point in the cycle crypto actually
turned first it returned first that
exponential age stocks then NASDAQ and
everything else came in in October
but crypto came actually eth turned into
forward-looking and I've been flagging
this to everybody as much as I can so I
really like this here's the secular
uptrend cyclical downtrend this is the
point every time that happens usually
it's like 10 20 30 50x from here
depending what you have
um you know bitcoin's not my bet here I
would probably choose to have ethereum
but we'll come on to that and so this is
um Bitcoin versus
the ism in yellow
fascinating every time they ask M Peaks
Bitcoin Peaks because it's money supply
and the business cycle that's driving
some of this it also bottoms before the
ism bottom so in in yellow or gold here
is the ism and Bitcoin log trend is
there and you can see the Peaks match up
perfectly
fascinating I didn't realize how
cyclical some elements this were in the
log Trend and I think everybody confused
it for the halving cycle and then it's
the halving cycle at all I think it's
actually driven by This Global monetary
cycle business cycle which is actually
driven because rates got reset in 2009
at zero everywhere globally and
everybody has to roll their rates I
think it's every three and a half years
you get a peak in the ism exactly three
and a half years and the and then
there's a low
um you know six months nine months later
and that is pretty much exactly cyclical
too and it's driven by the refinancing
cycle Mike Howells talked about this and
I think his work is really important on
liquidity and the refinancing cycle but
I think it's a bigger deal than most
people understand and again I urge you
to read the article I just uh written in
Pro macro or the really full stuff I've
written in GMI rule number eight is
understand recession what's the state of
macro investing right now
so macro investing is best summed up by
the word denial
so and people will interpret this two
ways people saying yeah the Market's
denying that it should go lower because
earnings are going to be revised lower
and we're going into recession
and my version of that is yes tell me
something I don't know
and markets are pretty clever they
forward look
so when I look at the macro data I'm
expecting a recession now I understand
it seems a bit not very clear because
unemployment's not moving yet stuff's
happening but
but the all my forward-looking
indicators suggest that we're going to
go into a recession
but what is unexpected it looks like
it's not going to last very long
so the forward looking stuff based on
liquidity and I'll come into why this is
important to say is actually saying that
after about April things start improving
so we we go into the Vortex now of
everything's going to feel terrible the
unemployment is going to start Rising
all of the data is going to come out bad
but the market I think is
forward-looking this turn in the data
and we've seen it with the Federal
Reserve the Federal Reserve kind of got
to the point where we're kind of almost
done they've gone from 50 basis point
rate hikes to 25 basis points and then
it'll be stop last time it stopped
Bitcoin went up 300 percent
uh East did about the same
the rest of the markets rallied you know
significantly so I think that's where we
are we're at the we're at the juncture
where the markets are sniffing at the
turn
that something is changing inflation is
going to start falling and the narrative
is going to shift towards we're in
recession now
and that's when everybody thinks well we
should be maximum bearish but actually
the markets are forward-looking and
start discounting an improved situation
whether it's more stimulus or rate Cuts
or whatever it is at least the FED
stopping raising rates killing all of us
number nine is invest in new tech the
next 20 years the next 10 years and
maybe even the next five years are
easily going to be the fastest rate of
change of technology and change to
society in human life
we don't even understand and we're
talking to a lot of the downfalls of
some of this stuff in due course
but I'm not worried about this I'm
trying to unlock your future some of
this is going to really fit your future
in 20 or 30 years time but we've got
time to figure that out
because it's Unstoppable
but what we need to do is make sure we
don't get disrupted and the only way of
doing that here is investing in it we've
talked about this exponential age thesis
all of these Technologies coming
together all at the same time that's
going to literally change everything we
understand about work life politics
culture the lot
and human life a disease and all of this
and it's not some pie in the sky stuff
it's all happening there's been Decades
of investment in this and the products
are going to start getting launched and
remember 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is be prepared
there is too much happening in too many
spaces in every single aspect of
everything we do as humans on Earth from
creating art to writing scripts for
films
to
the medical practices accounting lawyers
media
literally everything any single
absorption of knowledge has changed but
at a rate of which none of us can
understand a how to even catch up
but how to even understand it
and when I ask emad who's at the bloody
Center it all
where it's all going in five years time
it's like
it's moving so fast in so many unique
ways by so many people that we really
have no idea
but I think emad confirmed my view that
this is literally the biggest thing that
has happened on an economic and societal
level
in history in the shortest period of
time
and the ramifications of this were
Limitless forever
when I got started kind of March I was
short Equity markets betting they were
going to go down I'd started buying
Bitcoin I bought gold and I was long
bonds expecting rates to go to zero
which is essentially all played out so
it was an amazing period of time
then then we kind of settled into Trader
closed out my short positions in
equities because they're always
dangerous when the central bank's
printing unprecedented amounts of money
and I thought okay if they're Press
Printing unprecedented amounts of money
how do you capture that you know what's
the trade to be done and the trade was
this
debasement of currency and
um and the kind of people wanted to
protect their Capital so I was still
with golden Bitcoin and basically I just
started touring around with a Chance of
Bitcoin versus dot dot dot and looks at
anything
and it was like
well it's actually outperforming
everything on Earth and at the time it
hadn't started fully outperforming for
this cycle the central bank balance
sheets but other than that it was
starting to break down versus gold
equities NASDAQ you know copper I mean
you name it and I was like I called it
the supermassive black hole that I saw
that it was had a high probability of
outperforming literally every asset on
Earth and therefore it's going to suck
in all the capital and so I just closed
my goal position 100 into Bitcoin at
that point and then eventually broadened
out into other digital assets what gave
you the conviction to to to fade the
like tulip concept versus the like this
is going to stick around and be a part
of real macro
I'd written in 2013 an article about
stop to flow so I kind of thought well
if Bitcoin is digital gold then it
should have the same attribute so I kind
of figured out on a rough kind of back
of a bag packet piece uh you know
calculation is
okay how much gold is above ground how
much gets mined how much do we know is
in discoverable
um sources below the Earth and then kind
of back that out into Bitcoin and I
figured out with gold at the time is
about 1500
um Bitcoin should be a million and that
was I thought okay so and it was it was
at the time it was at 200 or something
stupid so I'm like okay this is the
wrong price
so that was the start I probably wrote
the first ever article about the kind of
macro valuation of of Bitcoin then
obviously Plan B independently and
brilliantly put together his Dr flow
model which even if it's not 100 perfect
gives us a conceptualization of of how
this might work because of this halving
and and the scarcity of the asset but it
was really discovering metcalf's law and
how it applied to networks that gave me
an understanding of how big this really
could be and once you look at things
that are network adoption models you
tend to find they don't mean revert like
a commodity that tends to have you know
not enough Supply which is going on
right now Supply meter collapses right
this can't happen in crypto just by
definition particularly in Bitcoin and
then when you look at it
all of these kind of events they look
like bubbles but they're all part of an
exponential Trend so once you put it on
a logarithmic chart it actually looks
pretty normal and that's how you have to
get a head around it and
humans don't think in non-linear terms
it's really hard for us so you know if
you take 20 linear steps out of my
office here you know I get to the other
side of the lounge if I take 20
exponential steps and go around the
world twice or something stupid so yeah
we can't get our heads around this but I
started looking at those charts figuring
out that figuring out how Network
effects apply to this and then realize
the only mean reversion is probably to
something like the three or five year
exponential moving average and that's it
so it's just an exponential curve that
keeps going but flattens out over time
as the network effects get more
saturated why do you think crypto is is
the answer to to the recession like
it's not the answer to the recession
it's the answer to the future of the
financial system as a start just as a
small stock is the fact that in a debt
Laden Society everybody owes everybody
money
and when things go wrong you don't know
who owes what to whom and that's what
happened with Lehman Brothers and many
of these other things is we don't know
who owed what because there's Daisy
chains of all of this debt
blockchain solves that you know
immediately who's the owner of the asset
also gets around a lot of other Legacy
financial problems you know ownership is
one there's problems within custody
um within the Deep hearts of the
plumbing of the financial system that if
somebody defaults almost everything
blows up and blockchain solves that
again because of this ownership issue it
makes transfer instantaneous so you
don't have two or three days settlement
periods and there was a number of things
but I also understood that it has
that's blockchain itself
but there's Bitcoin has these two
attributes one is the store of value so
it's like gold because it's a scarce
asset like artwork and other things real
estate
but it has this other thing which is
this call option on the future what
could it be what could it be useful what
could this technology be used for and
that's really the network effect that is
Bitcoin and it's the same for the whole
crypto space
so if it really was going to be a store
of value and the central banks were
printing an unprecedented amount of
money
then like Equity prices real estate
prices gold prices it should go up in
value
but it should go up a lot more because
it has this call option on a potential
future Financial system too so that was
really what I saw and the charts started
playing out exactly that way where
Bitcoin started outperforming every
other asset on Earth and it became no
point to own any other Assets Now this
year has been less that Bitcoin has kind
of kept pace with other assets but
um you know in a weird way it went up a
lot first and then came down a lot but
um over time it's generally outperformed
everything what gets worse about this is
this Affliction this crypto Affliction
we all get right the rabbit hole as it's
known you start with understanding money
which most of us don't think about then
you kind of understand how we're getting
screwed by Central Bank Printing and the
the debt Laden economy and what it means
and then you start saying okay but
that's Bitcoin and then what's this
ethereum business
and then you start realizing
decentralized finance and you're like
it's kind of a finance thing but that's
kind of cool because I can get yields
now you know I can get instead of
getting zero on my bank account for my
hard savings I can now get six percent a
year wow that's a difference it's like
going back 25 years in time
and then suddenly nfts come
and Community tokens and suddenly your
mind is completely blown that this is
not just money it's the entire exchange
transfer and storage of value
for the internet
whole business models are about to
change massively because of what this
technology unlocks and then once you get
that you head around that you're like oh
God I can't even hold this in my mind
any longer it's so big
um and that it's not just buy some
Bitcoin I'm gonna make some money over
time you know it's actually an entirely
parallel Financial system and business
structure for the world and it's being
adopted faster than anything we can ever
imagine how did I get here
and my journey was I was macro Macro for
30 years
it was
1997 where the world changed 97 and 98
was the Asian crisis the Asian crisis
was a sovereign debt crisis and a
corporate debt crisis that
wiped off the value of Asian stock
markets by 90 currencies collapsed 80 it
was a total Wipeout of wealth in Asia
and it was driven by debt
the answer to 1997 and 98
was to cut interest rates
long-term Capital Management the giant
hedge fund blew up at that time as well
the answer to that because it could have
taken down the financial system was to
cut rates
that led to firstly a massive rally in
equities and pouring of money into the
internet boom so that was a VC LED rally
plus all the stocks
that obviously ends up morphing into
where we are today the you know crypto
could not have happened without the
internet
but what happened over that period is a
massive debt bubble in property so the
debt bubble continued it in fact
accelerated
then it blocked the entire world's
banking system in 2008
nobody know who who'd owned what so when
Lehman went under everyone's like well I
don't know how do I get my stuff back
and they're like well it's not your
stuff it's been rehypothecated 37 times
so you can fight it out in courts and oh
by the way it's held in the Cayman
Islands London New York and Hong Kong
figuring out yourselves right that was
the mess we got into and people got
wiped out
then
we cut interest rates to zero and
invented concept of easing which the
Japanese have been kind of trialing
beforehand
so now we're pushing money into the
banking system and we have rates at zero
and so humans being humans go well great
we'll just borrow more money and they
just keep borrowing money
so
all of us in Mac have been watching this
and talking about it for a long time 20
years long time and we knew you know
business Cycles only come along once
every five to eight years
and it all comes to a head in a
recession
so 2008 you kind of knew was coming
because of what had happened in 2000 and
what had happened in 97
and the piper was going to get paid
and the Central Bank figured a way out
of it
then suddenly this event happens last
year there was going to be a recession
but the accelerant was the pandemic
so it blows up everything
and the world could have blown up again
right all everybody should have gone and
told them because the world's shut down
for a year
but the government just said no here
take free money and the central bank
will just print it
so we now know what it's doing to the
value of our savings because these
assets are going up we're actually
getting poorer in our future selves
[Music]
and so the macro guys start thinking
well how the hell are we going to get
out of this cycle it's either going to
blow up spectacularly but the odds are
getting less or we're just going to get
poorer slowly over time so it's a matter
of how fast you figure out what's going
on
so once you figure out what's going on
you look at crypto and it solves a lot
of this so when Bitcoin first comes
along it's clear it's developed solely
for this job I mean it's very clear in
the white paper and it's very clear when
they're looking at the banks being
bailed out again that somebody figures
out why don't we try a scarce digital
asset and see if that works
and then about a year or two after that
people start figuring out oh blockchain
oh that kind of is interesting but other
stuff because we've got now a trusted
ownership structure which the world
didn't have then Europe blows up in 2012
as well we almost lost the whole of the
European Union and all of the banks so
we kind of know it's a big problem
and then ethereum comes along with smart
contracts and then the kind of light
bulb moment for everybody goes off is
like actually we can rebuild the entire
system from scratch
so as a macro guy when you know you've
got something fundamentally broken
and there's only one set of outcomes
which is printing more money
we've got this low growth from this
demographics and technology and all of
these things have been changing the
world so we've got
we've got low growth massive debt makes
it hard to service the debt increase the
amount of printing
so therefore these assets go up
but the real macro opportunity
is to invest in the new world what is it
that makes Bitcoin interesting enough
that so many smart people see this as
ultrasound money and what does
ultrasound money mean
the world has a history of money
whether it's backed by gold or not
where government
gets themselves excessively into debt
and they devalue the money
so the Romans used to clip the edge off
the coins so there was less gold in each
coin
and eventually people would lose faith
in the coins because they blend them
with silver and then blend them with
copper and you know the coins were
worthless because that was supposed to
be worth the value of the of the Denari
in Roman times
but governments can't help themselves
humans we're just humans right humans
are fundamentally flawed creatures and
we always will be
so then we have these gold standards you
know the US and the UK are on gold
standards World War One World War II we
all have to leave it because we've got
too much in debt again
we've overly financialized yet again
because humans love leverage above all
things it's kind of sex and leverage are
the two things that drive humans for
some reason
then we adopt a new system which has
been around before but it keeps getting
abandoned called Fiat money Fiat money
is money not backed by anything
backed by the promise of the Central
Bank paying it so that's the dollar bill
that we all are familiar with and every
country in the world now adopted fiat
currency
but
as with everything
if you're really thirsty and I gave you
a bottle of water or sold it to you you
probably pay me 10 times too much for
that bottle of water
if I give you a million bottles of water
they're worth precisely zero to you
so scarcity has value that's Arts that's
cars that's almost anything
um humans value scarcity for whatever
reason we do
um and so if you're printing too much
money
you're creating less scarcity so yes
there's money everywhere
but the money has less value
so once you understand that
you say well what does it mean the
dollar hasn't collapsed it's kind of
where it was versus the Euro in the last
five years or whatever it is
and then you say huh
but my fifty thousand dollar salary
now can buy me much less shares in apple
Amazon Google Microsoft in fact units of
the S P 500 right I suddenly can't buy
as much since 2008 it's a fraction I can
buy like
a third of what I could
same with real estate same with gold
and then you're like huh
assets have suddenly got expensive they
haven't
the value of your savings has gone down
or your money
so you can't afford to buy assets what
is an asset an asset is deferred
consumption from the future
I buy a house
I sell it in the future I get to retire
whatever the the things are right we
don't buy the s p because we want to
hang it up in our wall we buy it because
we want to sell it at a future date to
realize money
so that means our future selves in our
poorer that's essentially what this
means that's what currency debasement is
so Bitcoin comes along in 2008 in the
middle of the crisis it's kind of like
it was perfectly prepared for this and
said
Satoshi goes hey look at this
I can create an algorithm
that only creates so much of this thing
the Bitcoin
and it can never vary ever
so therefore this is scarcity that
humans can't around with
now humans have this propensity to
around with scarcity because they're
economically incentivized to do so
here they can't
so then they become economically
incentivized to own this asset because
it's scarce and it cannot be changed
because it has this consistent supply
curve and a limited number
so Bitcoin becomes this great store of
value
and it would look like gold because
Gold's a good story values work for
thousands of years but Bitcoin has this
other thing to it it's a network which
gold isn't and it's technology which
gold isn't so we have use cases and the
benefits of building a network so sudden
it goes up exponentially in price
roll onto 2015
and suddenly somebody's looking at the
blockchain
and they start saying
imagine if these bits on the blockchain
which is where you record the ownership
of something in Bitcoin it's Bitcoin
itself
what happens if we could put contract in
there
because humans live off contracts you
know everything is basically a
Contracting in our legal terms
and that was the rise of ethereum it
became a platform where you could
programmably change the blockchain not
the attributes of the blockchain you
couldn't remove anything off that ledger
but you could change the little holding
buckets and say well it can look like
this could look like that it can adopt
to this
and those things were verifiable as well
so they couldn't change
so this created a theorem which became
the platform so if you think of Bitcoin
as this store of value this very
pristine beautiful thing
then you think of ethereum as also a
very beautiful thing but it's a much
broader application because it's like
programmable money what have we seen
over the last nine months in the macros
story of crypto has there been more of
that convergence are they now close to
one in the same or what's changed
so I think they're the same so if I go
to my peer group
and the people I really respect from
macro hedge fund space right so that's
the pointy end of macro those are the
guys almost all of them have
transitioned across in one way shape or
form either entirely
or partially really so like yeah I mean
it's very famous last nine months
or how long it's been happening slowly
but it's increasing you know it's going
exponential as all these Trends do so
you know people like Alan Howard
who's one of the world's most famous
macro investors based out of the UK
he personally is entirely crypto now
you know Dan tapiero you know good
friend of mine he's entirely crypto now
I'm pretty much entirely crypto
certainly my investments are I still
look at them whole macro world
but one after the other they're all
seeing the superior returns and a
solution for the set of problem macro
problems so macro guys generally tend to
be pretty pragmatic we've got a set of
problems solutions what's going to make
money allocate Capital accordingly but
everybody's going well this is the
biggest opportunity we've ever seen
because you start everybody starts on
the Bitcoin journey and ends up going
Having the Holy moment that everything
is about to change and I'm sure we'll
talk about a lot of that later
so I think macro encrypts have merged
what you're seeing now is you're seeing
a lot of noise from the latecomers to
macro
people who only know either the late
comes from macro or the ones that have
been around very long and are anchored
to gold and certain kind of mean
reverting ideas what you're seeing is a
fear of change
so the noise that you're getting at the
periphery the Peter ships of this world
for example
it's not that pizza shift doesn't
understand that
crypto is the future
it's that he doesn't want it to be
[Music]
because you made it
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome pretend more amazing rules from
Alex harmosi check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so many people at work me I still
make more money than them there has to
be something else one of the things that
grinds my gears about a lot of people
that I see on Instagram that you
probably see too is this whole like no
one can outwork me Mantra first off it's
objectively false